like many Disney movies Avengers and
Game threads the needle between age
groups trying to offer a solid story
that youngsters and adults can
appreciate but also adding enough mom
and pop jokes to keep mom and pop
engaged Avengers endgame had plenty of
things that went right over kids heads
spoilers ahead after the five-year time
jump early in the film we see Captain
America leading a grief counseling group
meant to help people move on after a fan
osis snap with half the living creatures
in the universe gone there are a lot of
issues left unresolved all the surviving
Avengers are struggling to move on after
the weight of a crushing genocidal loss
that's beyond alien to most kids adults
on the other hand are more likely to key
into what are obviously some largely
unhealthy coping mechanisms for the
Avengers loss of them all Tony is the
closest to moving on in a healthy way
but he's done so by moving as far into
the country as he can so as to never
engage with the wreckage of his biggest
heartbreak he's deep in denial to the
point where he kicks the Avengers out
when they try to convince him there's a
chance to make things right it wouldn't
be an exaggeration to say that both
Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame are built on father issues
you've got the ultimate abusive big dad
and Thanos who tells everyone he meets
that his genocide a war path is all for
the good of the people he's killing that
he's actually being the good guy by
doing the bad thing for the right
reasons then you've got Tony Stark who
struggles with being a father figure for
Peter Parker and for whom the latter's
death weighs heavily enough an end game
to lead Tony to undertake a mission
through time to bring spider-man back
then there's Thor who often struggles
under the weight of his own father's
expectations basically a lot of The
Avengers are working through their dad
issues which is crystallized in a long
moment of Tony talking to his father
Howard Stark while on a mission through
time in the 1970s tony manages to have a
pretty in-depth heart-to-heart with his
old man
even though howard has no idea that he's
actually talking to his son tony finally
gets to work through some of his
feelings and admit that howard was a
pretty good dad underneath it all it's
the kind of perspective that you're not
likely to get unless you're well on your
way to becoming the dad yourself what is
and always will be
my greatest creation
is you when Thor and rocket go back to
Asgard to get the reality stone the god
of thunder pretty immediately gets
sidetracked when he sees his mother
Frigga Thor remembers that the day
they're visiting Asgard is the same day
his mother dies in the past which brings
up some understandably complicated
emotions for him Frigga finds him
however and they're able to have one
last loaded conversation about family
the future and the burden of
expectations it's the kind of perfect
last conversation that many adults wish
they could have had with their parents
after they passed that level of
melancholic fantasy isn't common for
most kids thankfully and the opportunity
for Thor to have one last chat with his
doomed mother likely put more than a few
adults in the audience to tears real
people don't have the ability to go back
in time and get closure with their
parents but plenty have dreamed of the
chance while Captain America has been
leading therapy sessions and Natasha has
been leading superhero teams Thor has
been leading new Asgard at least in
terms of alcohol consumption the massive
amount of alcohol Thor has been drinking
has given the God of Thunder a bit of a
beer guts which leads to a handful of
fat jokes throughout the rest of the
movie
he's clearly dealing with depression and
grief and it's led him into a
destructive lifestyle that's radically
changed his body kids may or may not
recognize that Thor's newly rotund
figure is a product of beer drinking and
they certainly aren't going to clue into
Thor's decision to look for a way out of
the emptiness of his life at the bottom
of a bottle when it comes to time travel
in movies things almost never make sense
for very long most of the time these
movies just kind of ask you to accept
the basic concept and ignore anything
weird that happens later end game
however spends a lot of time calling out
various misconceptions about how time
travel works in the MCU movies get
involved when rody and Scott Lang list
off some of their time travel favorites
Back to the Future Hot Tub Time Machine
Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure
Star Trek quantum leap time cop and The
Terminator
most kids aren't going to have seen more
than a couple of movies on the list and
they rattle them off so quickly that
even adults might have trouble keeping
up still even if you were quick enough
to recognize the films and remember each
one's specific rules regarding time
travel it doesn't matter
Hulk pretty quickly shuts Rodian Scott
down immediately by telling them that
there
all wrong after Scott finally escapes
the quantum realm thanks to a helpful
rat he has to alert a security guard to
let him and his quantum realm doohickeys
out of the storage space they're being
held in that security guard is played by
none other than Ken Jeong
who's previously worked with the Russo
brothers on the series community and won
a to a change [ __ ] the cameo alone
might be enough to mention here but
there's one more detail in that scene
that's just for adults the security
guard is reading JG Ballard's the
terminal Beach a collection of science
fiction short stories one of the most
famous stories in the terminal beach is
called endgame it doesn't bear many
similarities to the film but the share
title is certainly no coincidence
if you thought there was something
vaguely familiar about Thor's hair beard
and sunglasses
you weren't the only one Tony Stark
noticed too for a good chunk of the film
it seems like Chris Hemsworth Thor is
taking style lessons from Jeff Bridges
the dude of Big Lebowski pain I'm the
dude so that's what you call me
you know the r-rated cult classic from
1998 isn't a movie that most kids are
going to be familiar with but endgame
isn't content just to leave it as a
visual gag when stark calls Thor
Lebowski and passing it takes the quick
gag into meta territory bridges played
both the dude and also Obadiah Stane way
back an Iron Man stain was Tony's
business partner and eventually his
supervillainess rival as Iron Monger
that Tony is the one to call Thor out on
his resemblance to one of bridges as
less villainous roles is icing on a cake
that's just for the adults in the
audience just because it's a serious
mission doesn't mean there's not a bit
of room for levity ant-man and Iron Man
certainly take that to heart when they
journey back to 2012 along with Captain
America in order to get some of the
Infinity stones both Tony and Scott take
a moment to critique the past version of
Captain America's hindquarters in his
Avengers era get up ultimately Scott
proclaims it to be America's ass which
is hard to argue with later in the film
when present cap is fighting past cap he
takes a moment after the fight to admit
that he really does have America's best
but it's clear in just about every scene
for that rearward looking dialogue
likely to fly right over kids heads I'll
be it with some giggling that one of
their favorite heroes just set a mild
cuss word meanwhile the adults in the
audience are likely to feel a bit called
out for staring check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Avengers endgame or
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]